LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR
HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE YOUR NIELSEN. PROF THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED THREE MEMBERS
HERE WE WILL HOLD OUR VOTES
UNTIL THE END OF THE HEARING AS
SUCH WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEMS
LISTED FOR DISCUSSION WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSION SECTION ON THE
AGENDA TOGETHER ONCE AGAIN
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED WE WILL BEGIN
WITH ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PACKAGE WORLD
ADMINISTRATION- PLEASE ARE YOU
QUEUED UP TO PRESENT THE
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS SASHA
SAKE I AM THE DEPUTY SECRETARY
FOR HOUSING AT THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY. ON BEHALF OF OUR TEAM I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AT PRESENT THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS COMPONENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIANS. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
CALIFORNIA BLUEPRINT. THE
BLUEPRINT PROPOSES INVESTMENTS
IN PROGRAMS AND STRATEGIES THAT
ACHIEVE TWO GOALS NEARLY ALL
THROUGH EXISTING PROGRAMS. THOSE
GOALS ARE TO FIRST ACCELERATE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND SECOND TO
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO CREATE
HOUSING WHILE ADDRESSING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
WITHIN THAT STRATEGY THE
BLUEPRINT PROPOSES INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE SPECTRUM OF
HOUSING NEEDS. AND THE RESPONSE
TO AND PREVENTION OF
HOMELESSNESS. IS PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT ACCESS TO HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THE
COMPLEMENT OTHER LAND USE AND
HOUSING POLICY CHANGES ENACTED
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS. THESE
BUDGET PROPOSALS ARE IN ADDITION
TO THE ONGOING PROGRAMS WHICH
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE IMPLEMENTING
AS MANY AS YOU AS MANY OF YOU
HEARD OVER THE LAST FEW HOURS.
SO TODAY YOU'LL HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT LEADS ABOUT THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMPONENTS OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AFRAM AGENCY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARE ALSO PRESENT TO RESPOND TO
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS. BUT FIRST
STEP I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
CHIEF DEPUTY OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ZAC OLMSTED. PRESENT
THE COMPONENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU SASHA- I
STATE'S APPROACH CONTINUES TO BE
FOCUSED ON PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION AND PROTECTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE PROPOSAL
MADE AT THIS BUDGET SO ON
PRODUCTION- GOVERNESS MISS
PROPOSING TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
PROGRAMS THAT KEEP THE PRIMARY
GOALS. OF CREATING HOUSING FOR
THOSE MOST IN NEED. AND TO DO SO
IN A WAY THAT WERE REDUCE REDUCE
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT'S HOW FIVE HUNDRED MILLION-ARE BEING PROPOSED FOR OUR
POPULAR INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM. IS FOCUSED ON
INFILL PARCELS INCLUDING
BROWNFIELDS IN RURAL URBAN AND
SUBURBAN AREAS WHERE WE CAN
REDUCE VEHICLE USE THEREFORE
LOWERING HARMFUL GAS EMISSIONS.
INITIAL THREE HUNDRED MILLION IS
PROPOSED FOR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE WILL
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM IS GIVEN THE
STRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. A
HUNDRED MILLION IS SET ASIDE TO
FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO COVER
COMMERCIAL FACILITIES INTO
HOUSING AFTER REDUCE. AND
HUNDRED MILLION TO BUILD NEW
UNITS IN LAND CONSIDERED STATE
ACCESS. BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
THE NEW CONSTRUCTION IT OFTEN IS
IT'S TO PRESERVE THE HOUSING
THAT REMAINS AFFORDABLE TODAY.
FULLER TWO HUNDRED MILLION IS
PROPOSED RESERVE UNITS. IN ALSO
LOW VEHICLE USE AREAS INCLUDING
ENERGY RETROFITS AND MOVEMENT
TOWARD ELECTRIFYING NOTE THAT
EXISTING HOUSING. WE ALSO HAVE
TO DO MORE TO PRESERVE AND
PROTECT MOBILE AND MANUFACTURED
HOMES SO YOU SEE A HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSAL TO FOR EACH
YEAR TO WORK ON PHYSICAL
IMPROVEMENTS AND LEGAL CERTAINTY
OF OUR MOBILE HOME. AND MOBILE
HOME PARKS. THE ONLY THING I'LL
ALL MISSION CLOSING- IS THAT A
CALENDAR OF ALL OF OUR EXISTING
FUNDING ADMINISTERED BY HUD.
LOOK AT THE WHOLE. ON OUR
WEBSITE FOR EXAMPLE THE NEXT
ROUND OF THE THREE SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ACCELERATOR
WOULD BE IT WILL BE AVAILABLE
LATER THIS MONTH. AND A
SUPERNOVA OF SEVERAL HD PROGRAMS
THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM
THE USER FARMWORKER HOUSING
PROGRAM. IT'LL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM- PROGRAM IN THE
VETERANS HOUSING AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM. WHICH ARE
ALL CONSOLIDATED THROUGH THE- AB
FOUR THIRTY FOUR. THAT WILL BE
OUT IN MARCH SO EVEN AS WE-
PROPOSED THESE NEW INFUSIONS OF
FUNDING BOMB I ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO. REMEMBER THAT WE
ARE STILL DEPLOYING QUITE A BIT
OF FUNDING OURSELVES AND TO LIVE
SEE THAT COUNT OUR WEBSITE.
THANKS AND HAPPY TO PASS ALONG.
TO MY CAL POLY CAL EXPECT. THANK
YOU DON'T. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
CHAIRED NUMBER ARE CAN BE. BRIEF
OPTICAL CALIFORNIA. PROPOSES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. INVESTMENT
MIXING HOUSE WHICH SUPPLY NEEDS
FUNDING COLLEGES TAILORING.
ANNUALLY FOR THE PURPOSE THROUGH
SB- THIS PROGRAM FINANCES
PROJECTS STRETCH WHY ACROSS
INCOME. SCREEN OKAY. UPON
MOBILITY COMMUNITY ACROSS. AND
MORNING. CRUISE ISLAND SETTING
PATTERNS. THE BUNCH ALSO
PROPOSED A NEW HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR CASE FOR THIS. KNOWING
HOUSING CREDIT PROGRM IN RECENT
. AND IT WILL BE THAT WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
TAX FOUNDATION COMMUNITY. OFFICE
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
AVAILABLE TRY TRY TO QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DESERVED
CLUE THE- PRESENT. YES THANK YOU
WE JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW- AND BE ABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT
FINANCE- ANY COMMENT. AFTERNOON
CHRIS COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THAT
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AFTERNOON THIS
MARVELOUS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THIS WEEK OUR
OFFICE RELEASED A REPORT
PROVIDING OUR OVERALL COMMENTS
ON THAT THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING
PACKAGE ON THOSE ARE REFLECTED
IN SUMMARY IN THE AGENDA BEFORE
YOU TODAY- BUT JUST A FEW
ADDITIONAL- HIGHLIGHTS. IS
WANTED TO KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
TO CONTINUE OVERSIGHT ON THE
MAJOR INVESTMENTS AND PROVIDING
IN RECENT YEARS I'M JUST REALLY
THAT THE FOCUS OF THE DISCUSSION
EARLIER TDAY. ADDITIONALLY
NOTING SORT OF A SECONDARY
BENEFIT IDENTIFIED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TOWARDS USING
HOUSING AND SELECTING TO WHERE
HOUSING IS LOCATED AT THAT WAY
TO SORT OF ADDRESS STATES
CLINICAL CERTAINLY SORT OF
MERITORIOUS IN A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT IN A MORE
WORK WILL BE NEEDED OVER THE
LONG TERM TO ENSURE SORT OF
THERE'S NO FULL ALIGNMENT INTO
THINK ABOUT CLIMATE LEARN MORE
ONGOING BASIS TO MAKE HOUSING-
POLICY DECISION. FOR MARCH THE
PROCESSING HOW THE PACKAGE AND
TO SEE FORWARD AND IT'S GOALS
WILL BE OF. IN PARTICULAR
THINKING ABOUT HOW THE BUDGET
PACKAGE A LINE THE B. C. A
POLICY. TAKEN FOR THE LARGEST
STUFF EXAMPLE NO RECENTLY TO
STREAMLINE PROCESS. TO ALLOW- TO
A CERTAIN BILL TO PUTS ARE SPLIT
DOWN LAW INTO THE UPPER TO BRING
A- BETWEEN BUDGET AND POLICY
INTENT PERHAPS ANOTHER- ACTIONS
CAN BE FORWARD. ADDITIONAL INTO
AREAS OF THE BUDGET THE STATE OF
LIMIT WILL BE ON IS AN WILL BE
COULD TO BE AS OF A MAJOR
CONCERN. IN THIS NOT BECAUSE
OUTLAY PER ARE EX FROM THE FALLA
OF THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE IF
THERE ARE ALLEGATIONS THAT YOU
CAN BE EXCLUDED THE LEGISLATURE
CAN'T ALLOCATE MORE FUNDING
TOWARDS THIS PROGRAM CAN MAKE
OTHERWISE BE- BE AVAILABLE DUE
TO SERVICE OUR CONSTRAINTS. I
MEAN ULTIMATELY SORT OF ANY
PACKAGE OF THE LEGISLATURE- DOES
AUTHORIZING A WEEK COULD YOU TO
THINK THAT- HAVING STRONG SOARED
TRACTOR. AND ENSURE THEIR A KIND
OF THE ME FORWARD WILL BE VERY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
FOR YOUR COM- REALLY APPRECIATE
THOSE- WE'RE GOING TO BE THE
ISSUE BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE AND
SEE IF THERE. QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. US SAYING NINE I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. I IN
THE- TO THE AFFORD HOUSING THE
STATE OF. COMMUNITY GRANDPA. IS
THAT SET ASIDE FOR A- STILL TEND
. OR HAS IT INC. AND THAT MAY
NEED TO COME FROM MR OLMSTEAD.
WHILE WE ADMINISTER ON BEHALF OF
THE SPEAKER COUNCILS THE RIGHT.
SET OF POLICIES BUT- SO BILLS
COULD ALWAYS CERTAINLY BE
ADDRESSED AT THIS RECALL COUNCIL
BUT THIS AUGMENTATION IS
ESSENTIALLY ADDITIONAL FUSION
UNDER THE CURRENT RULES. ALL
RIGHT SO YOU CAN'T TELL ME
WHETHER IT'S STILL 210% OR
WHETHER IT'S BEEN INCREASED.
IT'S OKAY IF YOU DON'T KNOW. I'M
JUST NEED TO KNOW YEAH I CAN I
CAN EASILY OTHER COLLEAGUES TO
GET THAT INFORMATION TO READ
BACK YOUR CHRISTENING UP YOU
WERE GOING TO PLAN. YEAH CHRIS
COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS AS I CAN TO CREATED THIS IS.
THE PROPOSED- INFUSION GENERAL
FUND IS IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
EXISTING- AGENCY PROGRAM SO
THERE'S NO PROPOSED CHANGES TO
THE SATISFIED BUT- AGAIN WE CAN
CONFIRM THAT WAY R. O. PR CAL.
COLLEAGUES THAT WOULD BE GREAT
SO MY POINT THERE IS THAT. IN
THE PAST. THAT CAN PERCENT SET
ASIDE WAS CREATED WHEN I WAS ON
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL AND
SPECIFICALLY. BECAUSE NO RURAL
COMMUNITIES COULD QUALIFY. WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU COME IN WHEN YOU
CREATE A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM AND THE AWARD IS GIVEN.
TO REDUCE CLIMATE CHANGE. YOU'RE
pAND YOU WILL NEVER EVER HAVE
ENOUGH POINTS IN ORDER TO BE TO
QUALIFY SO. SO THE PROGRAM
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE CREATED A SET
ASIDE AND I AND SO IF YOU COULD
GET BACK TO ME ON. WHETHER THE
SET ASIDE HAS BEEN INCREASE THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IN OUR
DELIBERATIONS BECAUSE IT MAY BE
THAT WE WANT THAT. SET ASIDE TO
BE IN YEAH INCREASED AND- THE
REASON THIS BECOMES PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT. IS AS WE LOOK AT THE
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS IN ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT FUND CATEGORIES
. THE DISTRIBUTION TO THE
WEALTHIER. COASTAL AREAS IS
COMPOSED TO THE INNER AREAS OF
THE STATE BECOMES PROBLEMATIC
THERE ISN'T THE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES AND SO THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE QUESTION AND IT
IS NOTICED. AND IN IN OUR- OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE RIGHT AT THAT- THAT
THERE THERE ARE FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES IN RURAL OR
UNDERDEVELOPED AREAS TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THE IF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. RESOURCES AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT IN THAT WERE WILLING TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF POOR AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL- I
THINK THAT'S ALL I. HAVE AS PART
OF MY COMMENTS I HAVEN'T NOTED
IN A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT PLACES
BUT I THINK THAT'S THE SUM TOTAL
OF ACT THAT ISSUE SO THIS IS A
WHOLE DOOR OPEN ITEM. FOR
FURTHER CONSIDERATION. AND WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS IN-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY-
BUSINESS AND CONSUMER SERVICES
IN HOUSING AGENCY AND ASK THE
AGENCY IF THEY'D LIKE TO PRESENT
ON THIS BILL. ON THIS REQUEST.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS WHERE CORD RESOURCES. HI
CHAIR WHEN THEY GRANT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AGENCY IN YES WE'D
LIKE TO PRESENT THIS THE TIME.
YES IT IS. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND- GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- AND TO ALL AND FOR THE
JOINT HEARING THAT WE JUST
LISTEN TO ADDRESS AND TAKING
NOTES AND VERY DILIGENTLY AND
JUST REALLY- ENCOURAGED BY THE
DIALOGUE IN THE QUESTIONS YES MY
NAME IS MELINDA GRANT AND
UNDERSECRETARY HERE AT THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. AS WELL AS- AT
BCA STATION MURRAY WHO STARTED
HER EXECUTIVE CAREER HERE WITHIN
AGENCIES SO VERY HUMBLE TO BE
HERE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY-
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO JUST START
OFF BY SAYING THAT THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU TODAY REQUEST
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS WORKLOADS
DATING FROM IN AN INCREASE IN
OVERSIGHT AND STRATEGIC
COORDINATION REQUIRED TO SUPPORT
EXISTING AGENCY PROGRAMS. AND
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN NEW
PROGRAMS POSSIBILITIES
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PORTFOLIO IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE AGENCY
CONTRACTED WITH A MANAGEMENT
CONSULTING FIRMS IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES AND ANY STAFFING
GAPS THAT EXIST IN THE CURRENT
OPERATING STRUCTURE IN THIS
PROPOSAL REFLECTS SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M JOINED HERE
BY OUR DEPUTY SECRETARY FISCAL
POLICY DIDN'T GARCIA AND OF
COURSE OUR COLLEAGUES. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE ARE
HEARING. ASKING QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY.
THE OTHER PART OF FINE ANY COM.
INTERNAL DEPARTMENTS FINANCE NO
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME AND WE HAVE A TICKET
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. WAS NOTED
IN THE PRESENTATION THERE HAS
BEEN AN INCREASE IN WORKLOAD AT
THE AGENCY LEVEL AND SO WE'RE
NOT RAISING CONCERNS WITH THIS
REQUEST. VERY GOOD ANY COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THEN. WE PROBABLY SHOULD
ASK YOU SOME QUESTIONS BUT WE
HAVE NONE SO- WE'RE DONE YEAH
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS THE ENCAMPMENT
RESOLUTION GRANTS. NASTIA AGENCY
TO PRESENT. MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
CALDERON IN THE GRAND STRECK
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS HOUSED
UNDER THE BUSINESS AND CONSUMER
. HOUSING AGENCY- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS REQUESTING A ONE TIME
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CHANGES TO PROVIDE
LOCAL ENTITIES WHICH INCLUDE
CITIES COUNTIES- AND CONTAINS A
CARE WITH GRANTS IN SUPPORT OF
PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS AND FOR
RESOLVING ENCAMPMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. I REQUEST WILL BUILD THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR TIME AND
HAVEN'T PROGRAM THAT WAS A STEP
FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR AND WHICH
WERE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING. IN THAT FIRST
GENERATION OF THE PROGRAM WE
RECEIVED NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSALS
FROM DIVERSE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS LIVING AND
CACTUS. AND AS THE DATA SUGGESTS
MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE. HE DATA
INDICATING THAT TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE ON SHELTER-
THAT IS THE HIGHEST RATE IN THE
NATION AND THAT REPRESENTS OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. THIS REQUEST WOULD
ALLOW US TO FURTHER INVEST IN
FLEXIBLE AND INNOVATIVE AND
CANNON RESOLUTION STRATEGIES.
AND SCALE UP TO THE SIZE AND
SCOPE NEEDED AFTER THE URGENCY
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AND I.
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRITNEY THOMPSON OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
BUT I AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HOW ABOUT
THE L. A. O. THANK YOU YES I'M
SORRY HAS ALSO RECENTLY RELEASED
A REPORT ON THE GOVERNOR'S
HOMELESSNESS- PLAN WHICH
INCLUDED MORE THAN JUSTIN KEVIN
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND
SO OUR GENERAL COMMERCIALLY DO
ALIGN WITH I SPOKE PREVIOUSLY ON
RELATED TO HOUSING AND NEED TO
HAVE TO DEVOTE ATTENTION TO
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT THE-
PRIOR RESIDENTS ARE WORKING WELL
INTO THE LINE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED YOU'RE
MOVING FORWARD. MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO THE PROPOSALS
ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY ON
ENCAMPMENTS WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT HERE THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION UPON THE INVESTMENT.
LAST YEAR WHICH IS A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- WELL WE'VE
ALREADY SPOKEN ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT NEED IN THIS CASE
ARE. GENERALLY ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT FUNDING HAS
NOT GONE OUT YET AND SO IT'S- TO
NOTRE. YOU KNOW WHAT
INTERVENTIONS. SORT OF OUR OUR
OUR WORKING. WON'T BE OUT IN
TIME FOR CONSIDERATION AS PART
OF THIS BUDGET CYCLE AND SOME
OTHER IS SORT OF GENERAL NEED-
NO NO WE HAD A SORT OF TARGET.
MEETING WITH EACH HOW. AND GIVEN
THE LACK OF DATA AND THE TINY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COMMITTEE COMMENTS ARE. THINGS
THE ONLY COULD. THE CONCERN I
HAVE AND I IT JUST TO COME IS
BOB IS IT WE WILL DON'T WE HAD
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THE ON
THE GUIDELINE- FROM LAST YEAR
AND IT SEEM TO ME OF. BIT WELL I
GUESS IT IT MAY MAKE MORE SENSE
FOR US TO BE MORE. MORE TARGETED
IN TERMS OF THAN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE PUT TO GO FROM
FIFTY MILLION TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IS- THIS IS SIGNIFICANT.
AND- THERE. UNLESS OUR RESEARCH
HAS FOUND THAT THE FIFTY MILLION
WOULD NOT MAKE A DIFFERENCE THE
DIFFERENCE IN HOW WE'RE DOING
WE'RE HOUSING HOMELESS TO ME IT
SEEMS IT IT MIGHT MAKE FUN FOUR
CENTS EVERY TROUBLE SPEAKING
THIS AFTERNOON MIGHT MAKE MORE
SENSE FOR US TO ALLOCATE THOSE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS GET AN
IDEA OF HOW THAT MONEY ROLLS OUT
BEFORE WE MAKE ANOTHER BIG
INVESTMENT- THAT IS- SO- SO
GREAT SO- TOUCHES MY COMMENT
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM SO WE
WILL BE HOLDING IT OVER OPEN FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION. AND I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING AND IT
THAT IS ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
WHICH IS ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND JUST MEMBERS. HI
MIKE MILLER TO OF THE SERVICES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. ARE
REQUESTED TO ADDRESS THE
DEPARTMENTS RISING
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOADS
INCLUDING APPEALS PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST. MEDIA OUTREACH
CONTRACTS AND PROCUREMENT AND
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES AND TO HELP
ADMINISTER STATE BY HE CRIME
HOTLINE THAT WAS APPROVED IN THE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. DURING THE DAY IS MERRY WE
ARE DEEPLY GFH CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. WE ALSO HAVE OUR
PROGRAMS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES FEATURES. OR HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. RISKE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENTS BED
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALEJO'S OFFICE. NO
COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YES THIRD CENTER UP
THANK YOU OF THE MANAGER JUST
CURIOUS SO WHEN YOU DO- EXCEPT
THE OF COMPLAINT FOR
INVESTIGATION I NOTICED THAT
THERE. THE ANALYSIS REFLECTS IT
AS OF JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO THERE WERE MORE THAN
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE OPEN CASES. WHAT IS
YOUR TIMELINE FOR- FROM CASE
FROM COMPLAINT INTAKE TO
INVESTIGATION COMPLETION. AND
DECISION POINT. RIGHT NOW THE
WAIT TIMES BETWEEN INTAKE.
REQUESTS ABOUT COMPLAINTS AND
THE ACTUAL INVESTIGATIVE
APPOINTMENT ARE APPROXIMATELY
THREE MONTHS FOR BOTH EMPLOYMENT
AND FOR HOUSING BOTH OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AREAS HAVE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS IN ORDER
TO COMPLETE INVESTIGATION
HOUSING INVESTIGATIONS
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
RELATED TO HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT. A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE HAVE TO BE
COMPLETED WITHIN ONE HUNDRED
DAYS SO THAT THE DEADLINE FOR
THOSE ACTUALLY SHORTER SO THE
COMPLETION DATES VARY DEPENDING
ON THE COMPLEXITY OF THE ACTUAL
CASE ITSELF THEY ALL HAVE TO BE
HANDLED WITHIN ONE YEAR. OF
BEING FILED. KARAMA YOU YOU SAID
THREE MONTHS AGO. IS IT TAKES
THREE MONTHS FROM COMPLAIN AND
TAKE TO INITIATION OF
INVESTIGATION CORRECT. OKAY. IS
THAT A STAFFING ISSUES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH HERE-
THAT'S- NOT PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE PART OF A
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEING PREPARED
AT THIS MOMENT IS PART OF A
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THAT WILL
BE COMING SHORTLY. TO INCREASE
PERSONNEL INVESTIGATORS SO YOU
CAN START THE INVESTIGATIONS
EARLIER CORRECT IN ORDER TO
DECREASE THE WAIT TIMES FROM THE
ACTUAL RECEIPT OF COMPLAINT TO
INVESTIGATIVE INTERVIEW AND TO
BEGIN THE- INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESS. SO WE KNOW THAT THE
INVESTIGATION START. ON THE
AVERAGE NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
COMPLAINTS ARE FILED. IN THE IN
DEATH TAKES THE REMAINING TIME
SO THAT SO NINE MONTHS- TO
INVESTIGATE GENERALLY. DID THEY
DON'T ALL TAKE THAT LONG IT'LL
TAKE THE ENTIRE TIME OF THE NINE
MONTHS BUT THE CLOCK DOES BEGIN
TO RUN WHEN THE COMPLAINTS
RECEIVED WE HAVE THREE ON SIXTY
FIVE DAYS TO COMPLETE. YOU HAVE
AN S. TIME OF COMPLETION OF
INVESTIGATION ONE STARTED FOR. A
COMPLAINTS OF DISCRIMINATION I
DON'T HAVE THAT BUT WE COULD
PROBABLY GET IT AND GET IT BACK
TO YOU AS QUICKLY AS YOU CAN.
WELL THAT'S FINE IS THAT
TYPICALLY DATA THAT YOU SUPPLIED
TO THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE PROVIDED THAT IN THE
PAST WE COULD IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
WOULD PREFER. WELL I'M NOT. I'M
JUST ON THE BOTTOM RUNG OF THE
LADDER HERE SO I DON'T MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS BUT- LET ME
ASK YOU ANOTHER WAY IS THAT.
DATA TYPICALLY CONTAINED IN THE
REPORT THAT YOU WERE. BUT I'M
SURE YOU DO AN ANNUAL REPORT
THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT PUTS OUT.
WE DO HAVE AN ANNUAL REPORT AND
I CAN LOOK TO SEE WHETHER THAT
PARTICULAR DATASET IS INCLUDED
IN THE REPORT OKAY. I WON'T
BELABOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSES SIR HAVE A GREAT DAY.
NO WORRIES THANK YOU. THIS ITEM
IS- HOLD. OPEN ITEM- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR QUESTION SENATOR.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD IT OPEN AND
WILL BE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
THAT REPORT- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. AND
THIS IS ISSUE ITEM NUMBER SIX
WHICH IS CODES FIELD OPERATIONS
STAFFING INCREASE. YES THANK
YOU- THE TERM HOUSING TO BE
DEVELOPED DEVELOPMENT IS NOT
REQUESTING AUGMENTATION OF YOUR
NINETY THREE THOUSAND STATE
OPERATIONS TO FIND THREE
POSITIONS- IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND- THESE DIGITAL BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASING WORKLOAD
RELATED TO HELP SEEKING RISK IN
OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS. ARE SO
THAT WE CAN PRESERVE- THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND WITH ME
IS OUR DEPUTY RECTOR FOR CODES
AND STANDARDS AND OVERSEAS THAT
WORK IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. RISKE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THAT
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU HELLO. MORALIS LEN WE HAVE
NO COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL. A
GOOD HUG COMMENTER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SINGMAN I
JUST HAVE- ONE QUESTION AND
THAT'S IN REGARDS TO- THE THERE
. DOES THIS REQUEST. ASSIST IN
THE. OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S TO PURCHASE THAT
MOBILE HOME PARKS. OR IS THIS
JUST STATE- A CODE ENFORCEMENT
POSITION. YES WE DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU NOTED-
THAT WE WENT OVER IN THE EARLIER
ITEM WHICH IS TO EXPAND SOME OF
THE RESOURCES AS WELL AS THE-
ACTIVITIES TO ALLOW ACQUISITION
OF MOBILE HOME PARKS BY
RESIDENTS ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS- BUT THIS IS A
SEPARATE REQUEST ON OUR-
ESSENTIALLY ARE OUR ABILITY TO
ASSESS CODE VIOLATIONS AND THE
AND THE LIKE ACROSS. PARTS OF
THE STATE VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH I THE REASON I ASK THAT IS
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS A BACKLOG- THERE ARE A
LOT OF TENANTS. COMPLAIN ISSUES
AND- I THINK THIS WILL HELP TO.
AT LEAST GET AN INSPECTION DONE
ON ON THOSE ISSUES SO THIS IS-
HOLD OPEN ITEM AND SO WE WILL DO
THAT. REMOVE BONTA ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH IS A CONSOLIDATED
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
APPLICATION PROCUREMENT PROJECT. THANK YOU- WE ARE PROPOSING TO
IMPROVE ON THE MONITORING AND
MANAGEMENT OF OUR LOANS GRANTS
BUSINESS PROGRAMS. THROUGH THIS
REQUEST ALL THIS IS THROUGH
PROCUREMENT OF ENTERPRISE IT
SOLUTIONS. ARE REQUESTING SIX
BILLION SEVEN OR THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS C. OPERATIONS
TO ASSISTANCE PROCUREMENT OF THE
NEW I. T. SOLUTION- AND THAT
ONGOING LICENSING SUPPORT. STILL
ARE THE ONLY THING ALL ADULTS
TRY TO BE BRIEF IS AS EVERYONE
HAS NOTED THROUGHOUT MANY MANY
HOURS A DAY OUR BUDGET ISSUES
INCREASED BY ACTUALLY FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN PERCENT. THE
LAST FOUR FISCAL YEARS QUITE A
FEW NEW PROGRAMS. 57% OF OUR
BUDGET IS NOT FEDERAL FUNDING
WITH ITS OWN OBLIGATIONS IN
TERMS OF REPORTING AND
MONITORING SO THIS REQUEST-
WOULD ALLOW US TO JOIN UP AND
LINK UP. ON MANY OF OUR KIND OF
DIFFUSE- MONITORING SYSTEMS I
HAVE A CHAU WITH US TODAY IF.
YOU AT LEAST YOU DON'T
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MUCH BOB DEPART OF FINANCE. NO
FURTHER COMMENTS BUT AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU HELLO. NO COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL BUT- JOKES WAS REGION'S
GENERALLY FROM NOTING WITH PRIOR
DISCUSSIONS YOU KNOW THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT TO THE DATA AND
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND SO YOU KNOW RAISING THE
QUESTION ABOUT SORT OF HOW THIS
PROPOSAL SORT OF A LINES- ON
WHICH TO MAKING PROGRESS IN THAT
SPACE AND IT SEEMS LIKE THE SORT
OF KIND OF HOW A LOT JUST. I'M
HAPPY ACCESS TO DATA TIME. GOOD
IS THERE ANY. ACROSS FROM THE-
SAYING NINE THIS IS A OPEN ITEM
WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN AND WE'RE
NOW TO MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I'LL GET THE MIKE
BACK TO THE CARE. THIS YEAR'S
ONLINE SEVENTY K. OKAY. SO MY-
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANY
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEM ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA. AS A REMINDER TO
DAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-4185 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. NINE FOUR ONE SEVEN FIVE
ONE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED MAY INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY AND TODAY I
AM GOING TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT
KEEP THEIR REMARKS. WITHIN ONE
MINUTE AND I HAVE MY- STOPWATCH
WITH ME SO NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BE IN. THANK YOU IF YO WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY. I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN Q. OKEY DOKEY. LET'S
START. THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND VERY MUCH THIS IS
PEGGY FONG AND A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN THE CITY OF YOUR
CALLING BACK I AM A- AND I AM A
REGIONAL MEMBER FOR THE PAST
CARE. SHE OF GOVERNMENTS
REGIONAL COUNCIL I REALLY LIKE
IT FRONT SUPPORT FOR IN THE
FINDING. INTEL IN PRESSURE GRANT
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM IS ON IN.
PUBLIC PRIVATE THE THIRTY AND
THE HOW TO. AND HAVE BUILDERS
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO COME A
COM NEW HOUSING. IN ADDITION TO
IN THE ALLEN CREEK THE FOR
TECHNICAL AT THE PROGRAM SO THAT
AND MEDIUM SIZED JURISDICTIONS
MIKE B. OF YOUR BILL AND ARE
ABLE TO COMPETE COULD BE TRYING
. TO SELL MY- FOR YOUR KIND.
THANK YOU. MATTERED THANK YOU I
HAVE TO MORE IN CUBA IF PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MONTERREY CLEAVE GIAMBRA
ADVOCATES FOR YOU WHEN LIKE TO A
ON FUNDING TO A COMMON THAT
AMONG YOU. FIRST WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE STATE CURRENT
TRIP TO ENSURING YOU ARE. OF THE
STATE MAINSTREAM HOME THE THREE
BY ESTABLISHING YOU SPECIFY WE'D
LIKE TO IN AND BACK AND HOW
WHICH THE CHANCE PERCENT YOU
BETTER. SECOND WE SEE A CRITICAL
TO IN TARGETED A TO ADDRESS.
AMONG YOUTH IN OUR STATE AFTER
THAT THE BUT I DO WE CAN CATCH
YOUNG PEOPLE YOU KNOW ARE AT
HIGHER OF THEY BECOME OF THE
STATE I'M A POP. WE WERE OUT FOR
AN ANNUAL AND BY. IF THERE FROM
DOLLARS INCREASE THE BUDGET FOR
THE TRANS. HOUSE PROGRAM AND
HOUSING NAVIGATOR PROGRAM. BOTH
MINISTERED BY EIGHT T. T. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE PRIOR. FOR TO COME.
CARE AND ARE REACHED. THANK YOU
FOR THE INVESTMENT MADE TO DATE
WE ENCOURAGE ALLEGED. TO ON THE
MOMENTUM I MAKE HALF ON GO PROBE
AND BY FUNDING THE THIRTY FOUR
MILLION TO. REDUCING FORM FOSTER
YOUTH ON A CO. THANK YOU. HERE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR.
REDUCING FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD DRASTICALLY REDUCE. AMONG
YOUTH FORMALLY AND ARE STATE
SPONSORED HERE THEM. DIRECTLY
FOSTER YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED
ALARMING RATES OF HOMELESSNESS
AS THEY TRANSITION OUT OF CARE.
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN GREAT
STRIDES TO ADDRESS THAT. ONE IN
FOUR FOSTER YOU. STILL
EXPERIENCE. AFTER ACNE. AND
BEFORE TURNING TWENTY THREE. FOR
USE ACTIVE THING THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
PLUS OR TEACH PEOPLE. THE RATE
IS EVEN HIGHER. 40% EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS PRIOR TO ENTERING
THE PROGRAM. NUMBER YOU THINK
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL WILL HELP FORM ABOUT
THREE ACHIEVE HOUSING STABILITY.
BY IMPROVING CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROGRAM. AND
ENSURING THAT THEY CAN MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL. HOUSING ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
SENATORS CABALLERO NIELSEN AND
ROCK DO YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. SEEING YES SENATOR
CABALLERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR I GUESS THE- THE ONE
THING THAT THAT I WILL SAY IS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS THE FOCUS
THE HEARINGS TODAY HAVE BEEN
REALLY GREAT- I AM CONCERNED
RIGHT MY INTEREST IS IN
UNDERSTANDING WHICH PROGRAMS ARE
ARE REALLY BEING SUCCESSFUL AND
BEFORE WE START ANY NEW PROGRAMS
OR WE FIND PROGRAMS. YOU WITH A
WHOLE HECK OF A LOT MORE MONEY
THAT WE KNOW WHETHER- WHETHER
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING AS WELL
AND I DON'T I DON'T MEAN WORKING
AS IN SOLVING ALL THE PROBLEMS I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MOVING IN THE DIRECTION
WHERE WORK. WE'RE HOUSING
PEOPLE. WE'RE LOOKING AT
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO DO IT. I'M
ALL HOUSING DOESN'T HAVE TO LOOK
ALIKE AND THE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
INTERIOR REGION OF THE STATE
ACCESS FUNDS BECAUSE THEY'RE-
THEY'RE READY. THEY'RE READY TO
ROLL AND I SOMETIMES IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO. ACCESS THEM BECAUSE THEY
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
NECESSARY SO BEFORE WE START
SOMETHING NEW IS WHAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE WORKING AND- AND ARE THERE
WAYS FOR US TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT MORE EQUITABLE SO THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ROLLING OUT GOES TO
ALL OVER THE STATE. APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS SENATOR CAREER ON
I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MANY QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED DURING THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN DURING
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING AS WELL.
AND THOSE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
WERE EITHER NOT ANSWERED OR THAT
WERE SLIGHTLY ANSWERED DESERVE
ACCURATE RESPONSES- BECAUSE TO
CENTER CABALLERO IS POINT. YOU
KNOW WE DO HAVE A BUDGET SURPLUS
AND SO IT'S NOT YOU KNOW. HAVING
THE MONEY TO SPEND TO ALLOCATE
ITS WHAT IS WORKING FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE WHAT IS WORKING WORK
BETTER AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE WHAT IS NOT WORKING WORK.
SO THAT WE CAN GET TO THE FINISH
LINE TOGETHER. SO WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY COUNTER DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BOAT
ONLY CALENDAR ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR CAFIERO
THANK YOU I'M- CABALLERO. I.
RIGHT YOU THAT MOTION IS
APPROVED. THREE TWO ONE HE IS
NOT HERE- SO IF ALL MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING HAVE VOTED YOU CAN
STATE THAT THE VOTE IN THE
BUDGET ITEM IS OUT THAT'S MY
WHEN I WAS WAS IS I SAW IT IS
OUT. BUT ARE WE GONNA HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN A LITTLE BIT FOR
SENATOR NIELSEN. WE ARE NOT OKEY
DOKEY- SO THAT ITEM IS THAT ONCE
AGAIN THREE. I AND I GUESS NO
VOTING I THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS. IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I AM YOUR
PATIENTS WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE SUPPORT. ADJOURNED.